that's you're lying to yourself yo
serena williams right best woman tennis
player ever played the game ever
again
no listen listen listen that's what i'm
saying listen so she said she was the
best like we all know she's the go live
serena williams
she said she would not be in the top 500
of men because of the like because there
was an argument like oh she might be a
man that uh it was just like physical
like it's like
genetics that's why they play three
games and that's why everyone's playing
no it's about one game no no i'm saying
women play three games men pay five so
that's what she's talking about the x
but like no no wait if she played five
there's there's still no chance no
that's what we're saying well also
this goes into the fact of
men are different women we're two
different species as humans that's why
there's double standard that's why men
can do something women can't you don't
have to pay for the club we don't have
there's so many why would you think you
could beat us in basketball i just
wanted to get a conversation
i feel like you would beat us 100
percent you would beat us
uh seven to eleven
but i thought when i was watching men's
boss what are you saying can you please
type up seven to eleven eleven to seven
seven seven buckets
please tell me
please tell me
if it was if it was me if it was me like
i'll take myself out of it so i tried to
be less biased well you've got one hand
so that's playing we got cast playing if
we keep playing
what's up
yeah but if you're let's say how much we
putting up you guys win but how many do
we put up
three i think if you if i think i think
there's a chance you like whatever shot
you're putting up is a hail mary to be
honest i think it's like wow it's a
random three and if it goes in it goes
in you're posting up someone that's
seven foot and you've never done it in
your life yes there's no girl that at
seven foot you know
yeah there's no girl that's six six
eight as heavy as jordan and can
yeah move like it's a layup yeah
yeah but it's still you still christian
but like what else is
[Music]
when i see women's women play they use
more of their heads
come on let's do it for themselves
if i got to pick between having to do
all these eloquent moves or just bodying
someone i would just pick the
a lot of these guys bumble the losers
say your chest bro
i'm just winding you up guys don't worry
i know you would win and i know you know
no no it's fine it's funny but do you
think
it's quite fun i've
liked him like i'd like he's physical as
[ __ ] he like my game that is just like
mad physical and i don't think
i could do i could i would be able to do
that that's facts that's [ __ ] like
he's like the monster plays like that
like if you do that to a like a woman
like it's not the same